Central Bank digital currencies will be  so tyrannical and those who want to  implement it no those are the world  economic Forum literally told us earlier  this year that if they were to implement  a central bank digital currency they  would also have to implement some kind  of new Bill of Rights in order to  protect our freedoms because of the  tyrannical nature of a central bank  digital currency now I don't believe  that this new Bill of Rights is going to  protect me at all we have the Nuremberg  code which is supposed to protect us  against forced medication what did they  do over the last two years well they  just threw that out the window and so if  they were to implement a central bank  digital currency with some kind of  fluffy Bill of Rights they wouldn't  abide by that and the slightest it  wouldn't even matter they would  circumvent it and find a reason which  allows them to do as they wish